hi metaphysical milkshakers it's raining
reza and we are here to tell you about
season two of metaphysical milkshake
that's right season two is going to be
bigger better and more milkshakely
delicious if that's a word then season
one
here's what you can expect we're gonna
take a little break to work on season
two
but we don't wanna leave your beautiful
ear holes empty so we are releasing some
of our favorite
only ever heard before behind a paywall
episodes that we've ever recorded
there's some doozies that's right you'll
get episodes each week revisiting some
of the amazing guests we had when we
first started potting together some of
the guests that you've never heard from
like for instance ebu patel the head of
the interfaith youth corps in chicago
we got another episode in which
rain wilson goes to greenland yeah i had
an incredible experience a couple years
back going up to greenland to do a piece
for seoul pancake on climate change got
to interview
uh dr david hick and dr gail whiteman
about climate change from the front
lines of climate change on the edge of a
glacier in greenland it was our first
remote episode that's right you could
actually watch the seas rise
as you were there
then we'll be back this summer with
season two and guess what we're not
skimping on the guests folks
we have jenna fisher and angela kinsey
you might remember them from the office
the office i assume that's a tv show or
something oh yes it is reza i'll fill
you in later we're also talking to tyler
henry everyone's favorite medium he
talks to dead people and will wheaton
which i'm like my chest is actually a
flutter just thinking
about having a chance to talk to will
wheaton for all of you trekkers better
show up for that episode king of the
nerds
of nerds we've also got weird al
yankovic
no
yes yes weird al that's right i just
appeared in his biopic movie playing dr
demento his mentor we've got adam savage
coming on the show to chat with us and
so many more so if you're not already
following us on your favorite podcast
app hit follow now or you can subscribe
on our youtube page so you do not miss
the brand new
bigger and better season 2 of
metaphysical milkshake also follow us on
instagram
and in the meantime enjoy some of our
favorite episodes starting next week to
get you through
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
so rain
i'm sure you've heard this before but we
are the most religiously diverse nation
in the world
something something we're pretty proud
of i hadn't even heard that before yeah
wow yeah uh pretty much every religion
known to man yep has a foothold here
in the u.s we got uh we got zoroastrians
here we got zoroastrian we have james we
got jane's i i i married a jain couple
not that long ago oh you married them
you didn't literally you married them
you you were the official
wait
let's not mention anything like that to
my wife just okay but yes yes i was the
officiate we got mormon scientologists
we got it all we got it all yeah uh and
on top of that yep we're probably the
most religious country in the developed
world it's hard to think of a
of a you know a developed nation that's
uh more religious in us that that we not
only um allow for religion in the public
realm we actually encourage it you know
i mean we give tax breaks to any
religion to do any kind of function
there's literally entire segments
of social work that the government has
basically given up
uh because they want religious and
farmed out to religious groups and i
mean religion certainly is the the
language of politics i mean imagine you
know somebody not being able to speak
that that language even when you're
faking it like trump does uh yeah you
still have to speak it and people in
europe can get elected as atheists oh
yeah they will run and just say i don't
really believe in god i don't know about
that and they're they'll win by atlanta
[ __ ] does not happen that's not going to
happen here you know you've got to have
even the ultra left secular folk will
need to talk about the importance of god
and prayer and yeah church in their
lives but i guess here's here's where
the conflict lies right is is in the
intersection of those two things yeah on
the one hand
a million different religions
everybody worshipping their own god
everybody with their own ideas and
rituals and practices and myths etc
coupled with
a country that is well let's face it
devoutly christian protestant 71 of
americans identify
uh as christian seven out of ten of us
if you can believe that that's kind of
crazy yeah
uh a country that constantly talks about
you know the the founding fathers and
the faith and the embedding you know god
into
uh the culture and and and the
government and our founding documents
what happens when those two things clash
which they often do right
can you co-exist with people that you
think are damned and are going to burn
in hell and and how how would you do it
right i mean
if you got two or three people
and they're in a room and each one
thinks the other person's you know wrong
and yeah and it's gonna burn in hell
and yet
you are forced to
live and thrive and help create a
functioning diverse pluralistic
democratic society how do you do that
what do you do
well
a friend of ours yes ebu patel chicago
based founder of interfaith youth corps
has a kind of idea about this and it's a
really
innovative idea when you think about it
yeah i you know i i went to an
interfaith meeting once and i was given
an award for some reason i don't know i
think they kind of knew oh that guy's a
baha'i he likes to talk about faith and
spirituality sometimes i bet he'll show
up
um so i went and had like
a filet mignon bad overcooked filet
mignon dinner at some you know marina
del rey ocean front steakhouse and it
was you know very diverse but old
everyone was in their mid late 60s and
patting each other on the back and a
hindu here and a muslim there and a
sikh there and it was pretty lame and
the more i find out about what ebu patel
does with his interfaith youth corps
it's young it's active it's service
oriented it's action oriented it's
getting into the communities it's
putting these kind of interfaith beliefs
into real action um it's it's really
exciting what i've learned about what he
does yeah and it's uh there's something
really sort of simple
and yet profound about it right
okay
we all come from different religions we
all believe
uh you know different things our
mythologies are different our rituals
and our practices are different we look
at each other as maybe saved or damned
we're never going to get past that so
this i let you know instead of like
sitting around trying to figure out a
way to kind of get past those
differences
just get the [ __ ] out of the room
there's work to be done yeah just leave
the room and go outside roll up your
sleeves roll up your sleeves build the
country that you want to build
and
that's where religious diversity can
become a powerful tool instead of a
dividing tool celebrate this diversity
celebrate the fact that we're the most
religiously diverse nation on the earth
and celebrate the fact that we're the
most religious nation on the earth as
well
and and get to work ebu patel is an
ishmaeli muslim and former faith adviser
to barack obama he's got an amazing book
out of many faiths religious diversity
and the american promise let's hear what
eboo's got to say your friend my friend
ebu patel
[Music]
so i am thrilled to be here my name is
ebu patel i am the founder and president
of an organization called interfaith
youth corps or ifyc we work on college
campuses uh viewing them as laboratories
and launching pads for interfaith
cooperation we think that uh religious
diversity is one of the great gifts and
challenges that america and frankly many
nations in the world face right now and
the question is how do you
take religious diversity uh and help it
become a healthy and positive pluralism
reza i think we could just end the
podcast right here i think it's done
yeah i think thanks that's my song
thank you so much so much it's great to
have you on the show exactly what we
needed
the reason that reina and i love what
you do is because what you want to do is
get these people of different religions
together
and to get them to move beyond their
differences and focus on their
commonality by putting them to work
right uh you you once said uh something
to the effect of these are people who
have a completely different idea of who
gets into heaven but they pretty much
have the same idea about how to fix the
earth and so let's just forget about
heaven for a minute and let's focus on
the earth because then we can you know
harness them and i think that's a
beautiful idea but it doesn't change the
fact that each one of them thinks the
other person's going to hell
right
right
and
uh when that comes up i have to gently
remind people that they don't control it
anyway
so
they it's not that that's not important
it's that part of the definition of
diversity i think is
being willing to disagree on some
fundamental things and work together on
others
and i'd say the the one amendment that i
would make to your description of of at
least ifyc's work is you don't have to
invent
the civic involvement of religious
communities in american life
religious communities play such a
massive role in american civil society
that it's like william carlos williams
red wheelbarrow so much depends on it
but you just don't notice it most of the
time because it's taken for granted
there was a near time story uh like 18
months ago about the city of mostar in
bosnia-herzegovina and it starts by
saying
when
uh you know mustafa who's a firefighter
in mostar hears that there's a fire on
the catholic side of town he knows that
he doesn't have to go because his muslim
fire department only fights fires in the
muslim side of town and it kind of goes
through all of the
different institutions of mostar from
the garbage dump to the nightclubs to
the schools to the soccer leagues and
they are all separated between serbian
orthodox christians croatian catholics
and bosnian muslims and this isn't a
city in hot conflict right and so the
big point that i'm making is that the
fact that we live in a country in which
it is just normal to walk into a
hospital i mean i think when you know
when zade was born my oldest child i
think i counted of the various like
pediatricians and and nurses and doctors
delivering
the baby i think there were people from
six different religions who over the
course of 24 hours were involved in
zade's birth and that's just like
standard operating procedure at
northwestern memorial hospital
something really interesting and special
about the united states specifically
that in other areas of the world you
wouldn't have this kind of necessarily
such a richly textured inter-religious
uh cooperation
in other areas of the world
it i think it is
let me put it this way
i think it is part of the american
genius that one of the ways religious
communities express their identities is
by building civic institutions schools
colleges hospitals social service
agencies that
explicitly welcome and serve people of a
range of different religious identities
and the kind of effort of ifyc or the
pragmatic dimension of what we do is to
say the more we can bridge how these
different religious communities act
together within their civic context
the stronger our democracy is the more
people get fed the better a disaster
relief effort goes the better a hospital
runs etc etc the religious diversity is
already present
the vast majority of the time it's
already engaged in what i would call
civic work right the kind of stuff that
most people
left right center trump supporter
whatever can generally agree
health care education social services
recreation the kind of stuff that
religious communities built in america
that that infrastructure is really
positive
uh
how do you do it better in a religiously
diverse country
this podcast is sponsored by better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue jesus i have all these rain i
think you need some better help reza
better help online therapy once to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress
in your life
and
it's such an important part of my life
um
therapy i i
i'm messed up i am i messed up i had a
crazy childhood there was a lot of
trauma i don't have all the tools to
function in the world
gee in case you couldn't have guessed
and places like better help are just
fantastic you really should check out
therapy this is a great way to start
your therapeutic process or to continue
it it's customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
and it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
metaphysical milkshake listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
milkshake that's betterhelp.com
milkshake
hey rain i know uh we did this last time
and it's just i swear to god purely a
coincidence but i am once again wearing
my buck mason shirt i am too wearing a
little buck mason got it going on
we all we all have like that favorite
you know go-to shirt right your favorite
sweater your favorite jeans your
favorite shirts stuff you wear all the
time
well guess what all of mine are buck
mason they're pretty fantastic i end up
wearing them all the time they're
timeless they never go out of style
everything they sent me just fits great
right out of the box becomes my new
favorite item of clothing right from the
get-go buck mason makes all the
essentials
uh jeans shirts jackets all my go-to's
so much more
i love the tailored look and fit of
their t-shirts
even after wearing them and putting them
through the wash time after time they
look just as good as when i first wore
them the curved hem tea rezza did you
try the curved mt
i got two of them it's fantastic gq
loves it as much as we do calling it the
best t-shirt in the game once you try
buck mason they'll become your go-to's
too head over to buckmason.com
milkshake and get a free t-shirt with
your first order that's
b-u-c-k-m-a-s-o-n
dot com slash
to get a free t-shirt with your first
order
buckmason.com
milkshake
here's i guess where my frustration lies
is that
you know i've kind of had it with
interfaith dialogue a little bit you
know this idea that oh well we'll just
you know we'll get a bunch of people
from different religions together we'll
sit them in a in a room together and
then they'll just all talk
um and then just in talking they'll find
out how much they all have in common
with each other and then they will it'll
just be a love fest and
that tends to not be what happens what
ends up happening is that people
um fall into sort of the traps laid by
their own doctrine in their own theology
and it seems like what you're sort of
saying is okay get out of the room
get get off the chair
and
go clean the streets
together go feed the hungry together
because you're not gonna agree on which
of you is going to heaven and which of
you is going to hell but you all agree
that hungry people should be fed like
that's not that's not up for argument
here right so let's just go do that
there's a great line by dorothy day uh
she says i want to build spaces where it
is easier for people to be good
and i think that kind of our version of
that line at ifyc would be i want to
build spaces where it is easier for
people to cooperate now the beautiful
thing is those spaces already exist you
just have to put the title cooperation
on them so at the chicago food
depository
they asked me to come in and to help
them answer the question
given that our most successful lobbying
days in springfield are
church and synagogue and mosque day what
does it look like to do an interfaith
day and what they are very reasonably
concerned about is
will the
commonality of advocating for more
robust hunger and homelessness programs
be drowned out by the differences in
theology and politics amongst these
groups and i would say that the person
and the reason that they haven't
organized interfaith day in springfield
is because they're not confident they
have the interfaith skills to do that
which is to say the skills to
de-emphasize the really important
differences and to emphasize the
dimension of civic cooperation right and
when i heard that story i thought to
myself there is some version of that
that's happening
in civic institutions across the board
somebody is thinking to themselves you
know what if we could get the doctors in
this hospital together and do grand
rounds on religion spirituality and
health it would really help us from
everything from like what you do what
families want done when a baby is born
to literally what's the definition of
death but we think that doing grand
rounds on that is going to bring up a
whole bunch of uh a whole bunch of of
theological disagreements and political
disagreements that we just don't want to
deal with that so they don't do it
so we have this tapestry in the united
states of
inter-religiousness in hospitals and
charity and whatnot and people not
necessarily getting in each other's way
accepting a muslim patient at a catholic
or a protestant or presbyterian hospital
let's say or at university or whatever
how do we go to the next level how does
interfaith work
take things to the next level because
isn't that where we need to go where
it's not just kind of like oh we're kind
of shoulder to shoulder and we're not
going to turn anyone away but how do
these different faiths and their
institutions
um activate
their faith into into greater action and
greater cooperation do you have specific
examples of stuff that you have seen
where they have actually come together
in a in a much more proactive way to
take on a larger problem with uh
efficacy the whole point that i'm making
is that we have these really special
spaces in america where people who
orient around religion differently
already come together what does it look
like to develop the language and the
skills to engage the religious diversity
in a way that gives you a better chance
at cooperation and i think disaster
relief is the single best example right
so you if you could get the synagogue to
be churning out a thousand meals a day
out of its kitchen
and you could get the mosque to serve as
a shelter and you could get the church
to be doing door-to-door checks if you
could coordinate that together
right instead of each of those groups
doing their own thing that actually
takes i think a lot more than literacy
that takes a real comfort with talking
to the leadership of those different
institutions and telling them listen the
synagogue is doing this the mosque is
doing that and the church is going to be
doing this other thing and you are all
in this kind of
holy sacred disaster relief assembly
line and you're gonna have to have good
communication with each other around
this right so and whoever serves the
most people goes to heaven
that's the right reason i'm actually
it's a big competition
that's actually quranic right that
there's there's a kind of a muslim
notion of competing in righteousness
well i win anyway um
i think the subtle but important
paradigm shift we are trying to
affect in interfaith work is go where
the money is where diverse religious
people are already engaged in social
action
and sim it's like the ingredients are in
the kitchen
right you have to put them in the same
pot what about um atheists i mean you
know this or not just atheists but
people who refuse to
apply any particular religious
identification to them
the so-called nons they're the fastest
growing movement certainly among kids
what's their role what are people those
without faith or those without a
religious label what role do they fit in
this in this holy diversity that you're
constructing
they have a seat at the table like
anybody else does
part of what we do at ifyc is we have
you know uh examples of faith heroes at
all of our tables and several of them we
are deliberate about are people who are
secular humanists or who are avowedly of
no faith a philip randolph is a good
example of a picture that we would have
at one of our tables so so in our view
they're
very much equal participants and that
should absolutely be taken into account
uh in however we understand the next
chapter of american history
i just want to jump in here because i
think there's something here that
that we're all trying to get at which is
like
what what is the larger point like i
think you mentioned earlier about
there's a holiness actually to doing
this work together can you talk about
that a little bit
so
i'll i'll tell uh i'll tell a story from
from islam so i think that it is of
great significance
that the first person who recognizes the
the prophethood of this you know
orphaned boy who becomes a merchant in
the city of mecca and who used to spend
uh the month of ramadan praying and
giving alms to the poor uh the first
person to recognize that when a force
grips him on the cave of mount hera in
the year 610 and forces him to recite in
the name of the of your lord who created
that that man was named wataka and he
was probably a christian monk
that it was a christian monk who first
recognizes the prophethood of muhammad
right and what i gained from that story
and lots of other muslim stories is that
there is virtually a requirement a
command within the tradition to have a
beautiful trusting relationship with
people from other religions
that it is not only pragmatic that when
a hindu and a muslim doctor perform a
surgery together they are in effect
reenacting
the sacred ritual of
recognizing the others
uh
the deepest parts of their soul in the
action of healing a patient together
right um
and there are you know one of my
favorite pieces of literature is
fraudulent
conference of the birds and it's this
story of
every
species on the planet recognizing that
they had a king or a representation of
god uh but the birds being so sad that
they didn't have one and the huppo bird
stands up and says actually we do have
one it's called the the great smurg and
he convinces this diverse array of birds
to go on this
massive journey across seven mountains
and valleys to to meet with the great
semerg and and when they finally get
there what they see is a reflection of
themselves in a shimmering mirror and
for me the fundamental lesson of that
story is that when a diverse group makes
a journey together it becomes a
community and that is a reflection of
god that is sacred right and i think
that that's the project we're embarked
on in the united states you know we're
the first nation to believe that people
from different
religions could come together and build
a country that is a massive thing
right
political philosophers
from the greeks until the time of the
united states thought it was impossible
rousseau famously says
you cannot live with one who you think
is damned
and jefferson and adams and madison and
franklin and washington and for all of
their sins and mistakes and their legion
they thought you could they thought that
you could build a religiously diverse
democracy and i think that one of the
most inspiring things about america is
how we continue to build on that right
so so the the the judeo-christian idea
uh or phrase wasn't etched on plymouth
rock when the pilgrims arrived it was a
response by a group of interfaith
leaders called the nccj in the 1930s a
response by them to the ugliness of kkk
anti-semitism anti-catholicism and
racism in the 1920s
they literally just made up a word
judeo-christian they said we're no
longer a protestant country
we're a judeo-christian country that
doesn't make any theological sense
because it's not like you know
jews consider jesus central at all and
it's not historically accurate because
it's not like jews fared that well in
christian countries for most of human
history but it's a brilliant civic
invention and we're on the brink of that
right now we're right judeo christian
did important work for 80 years and a
lot of people i know like to dismiss it
but think think to yourself would you
rather have been a jew in america in
1985 or 1925
and one of the reasons it was a lot
better to be a jew in 1985 was because
america absorbs this idea of a
judeo-christian nation which like
literally
80 years ago people just made up but now
we need a new word
we need something now we need a new word
we need a new word judeo muslim
christian
baha'i buddhist
pagan what is it that's gonna be you
guys in the next episode maybe our
listeners need to come up with what this
new word is it's no longer
judeo-christian which doesn't apply i
love that that was made up in the 30s as
a response to this racist organization
and we see so much kind of racist tinge
disunity especially in a lot of
protestant groups these days we need
that new word that new word that takes
us through the next century
milkshakers public goods remember that
name it's the one stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
personal care and household products to
coffee toilet paper shampoo pet food so
much more public goods is your new
everything store thoughtfully designed
for the conscious consumer rather than
buying from a bunch of single product
brands public good members can buy all
of their premium essentials in one place
with one beautiful
streamlined aesthetic
here's how it works public goods
searches the globe to find clean healthy
eco-friendly and innovative products
like for instance i got a box full of
cleaning supplies like hand soap
dish soap
you know counter cleaning
supplies all of that stuff because i
basically do all the cleaning in my
household
and
everything was all natural everything
was in sustainable
products and packaging uh you know it i
i still use it all the time like all
over my house or all these like public
goods cleaning products everywhere it's
fantastic public goods is committed to
making their products healthy and safe
for humans animals and the environment
they use a membership model to keep
costs slow and pass on even more savings
to their customers best of all you can
make your first purchase with no
obligation join hundreds of thousands of
others who have switched to their new
everything
bagel no everything store
we have worked out an awesome deal folks
receive 15 off your first public goods
order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you 15
to spend on your first purchase by the
way i just used their olive oil today on
my salad it was delicious
you have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com
milkshake or use code milkshake at
checkout that is p u b l i c g o o d s
dot com
forward slash milkshake to receive 15
off your first order
[Music]
okay it's lightning round time here we
go ready
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
uh when i wake up early in the morning
say my smiley muslim prayers have five
or ten minutes of silent meditation and
then have a nice iced coffee
describe your soul cold brew cold brew
just to beat this
stump town
um
describe your soul in 10 words or less
connected to god trying to be cleaner
who is your hero
jane adams
what do you hate
self-righteousness
what brings you joy
pensive white people's music
like the gr like is that wilco radio
head this is will that's exactly
funny it's basically our favorite
fans our two favorite fans we'll go and
radio let's all get together hold hands
in our religious diversity
yep and listen to mark said
white dudes in their 40s
what do you want your final meal to be
probably a masala dosa
what do you want your death bed to look
like
[ __ ] seriously
wow i had a nerve really i hit a nerve
i mean you couldn't have just ended it
with final meal
well what am i supposed to say
covered with flowers i don't know that's
beautiful i love that i want to see you
covered we did a whole episode
did reza say littered with virgins
that's exactly what i said yes
i want to be buried uh beneath a pile of
virgins um
and finally what is your life's big
question
i think his life's big question is about
that deathbed yeah that's what i think
by reza's deathbed it's a combination of
the two so go ahead what is your life's
big question
how do you build a healthy religiously
diverse democracy and make sure that
it's holy
ebu patel
thank you so much for putting up with us
it was great to be with you
[Music]
listening to ebu it reminds me of um my
favorite verse of the bible comes from
the epistle of james uh james who was
literally the flesh and blood brother of
jesus and uh people know this it's a
it's a very famous line but uh they
don't know who said it
faith
without works
is dead
yeah faith without works
is dead and
look you know i i
i vacillate between optimistic and
pessimistic
between you know
oh this country is so beautiful in its
diversity and this [ __ ] racist
country
and you know let's face it we're at a
time right now with a lot of
conflicts uh manufactured conflicts
between religions a lot of religious
bigotry uh and so i think about the
diversity of this country and i'm in one
of those moods where i don't see it as a
strength i see it as
a source of conflict but maybe this is
maybe it's in that line from james right
maybe that's where the answer is
faith without works is dead so
[ __ ] your faith forget about you know
whether you believe in jesus or whether
you worship allah or whether you follow
the buddha or
whatever and instead
let's just all
put whatever it is that we believe
into action
and that's where our solidarity comes
from so
that question that ebu asks can we
create a religiously diverse democracy
in america the answer is
yes
if
we work together we work yeah and we
work together together yeah um yeah i
mean that
that phrase that saying from james is at
the center of one of the greatest
theological debates in
the history of the christian church of
course because paul i don't know what
verse but what people gleaned from paul
and paul may not have even meant this
but
he is
interpreted as being well you don't need
to do works you can just believe in
jesus if you just give your heart to
jesus you get baptized
you say jesus take away my sins
uh i'm yours take me away um
nothing you can do to earn
salvation you can't earn it yes there's
nothing you do it's only in the in the
act of seeking grace that you're
redeemed
uh so those two things are really at
odds they really are and i would say
it's that paul idea
which is so often the one that i think
keeps us
um
in conflict with each other right
because if you think that all you need
is faith
then
it doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter what you have in common you can
be an [ __ ] your whole life yeah ask
for forgiveness say jesus i believe in
you and you go up to heaven yeah so and
and my faith is the right one your faith
is the wrong does it sound like we're
dissing on christians right now i don't
want we're not using on christians i
don't want christians to be listening to
this and going like those [ __ ] i
guess we're dissing on paul
[ __ ] that guy
um yeah so i mean maybe this is the
answer maybe it's uh we gotta stop
talking about
the beliefs that we have in common with
each other and the we all in the end
worship the same god i mean i believe
all that stuff i think it's true i just
don't think it's very effective because
when you say to some people hey we all
worship the same god they say no we
don't no i worship god you worship the
devil
but if i say to that person
do you think hungry people should be fed
do you think homeless people should be
housed
i mean well we can matter which god you
believe in you probably agree with those
statements right well ebu
referenced uh the fact of people coming
together in disasters and emergencies
and people came together during 9 11.
yeah there was a lot of anti-muslim
uh rhetoric out there but at the same
time
there was also a great deal of people
reaching out to muslim communities and
christian and muslim communities coming
together and jewish ones too
i just think we need to do it beyond the
scope of disasters and emergencies or
rather shift our thinking to the fact
that we're in a constant disaster and
emergency we're in an age of uh
incredible amounts of suicide there's
mass shootings all the time we've got
immigration
crisis we've got a climate crisis that's
that's out of control a political system
that's deadlocked we're in the disaster
right now yeah we're living day by day
week by week year by year in a disaster
zone so just the same way that people
pitch together during the haitian
earthquake or hurricane katrina we have
to do that on a daily basis people of
all faiths put away the differences
focus on
the things that we have in common which
is putting our values into practice
that's a beautiful thought and i suppose
if you're in a faith community you can
contact the interfaith youth corps and
find out some
effective handy ways to do that i don't
know or alternatively you could contact
us
transition that is a good transition a
century
wow you can find us on
our socials at reza aslan at rayne
wilson make sure to use the hashtag
metaphysical and i don't know like tell
me which which reza aslan do you
associate with the reza aslan who's like
you know well we're all just gonna eat
each other which i am on like you know
tuesdays and thursdays
or the
aslan that's like you know what we can
come together focus on the things that
we hold in common put those values in
action and there's your there's your
religiously diverse democracy
you know i think pessimism is a soul
killer i think it's so easy to fall into
it's an easy fallout i think the world
kind of wants you pessimistic optimism
is hard
and requires kind of more work
and
uh i i like the optimistic reza better
and
i but i have the same struggle i have
the same i'm not above that in any way
shape or form but there's some other
questions that i want to ask our
audience too you know we talked about
judeo-christian being this invented word
what's the new word that takes us
through the next century um of diversity
of religious diversity in this in this
country and and also
what is the holiness
of interfaith what is the holiness of
diversity where's that spiritual element
that
goes beyond and through those words yeah
is it a sacred enterprise is it a holy
enterprise yeah and how do we take that
feeling into action so many questions
brought up by this episode again at reza
aslan at rayne wilson
metaphysical and you can email reza at
his personal email which is
reza.assmann
aol.com
please don't email me at askman.org
just text him at one three one no
thank you again to our guest ebu patel
ebu keep fighting the good fight man see
you next time
so long
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem himself and dj lubel
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowell sarah
pellegrini mary phillip sandy and shelby
sandlin original music by jeff tang and
scott tang
[Music]
talk about diversity look at the
diversity of names that we've had on
this freaking podcast it's crazy we just
had ebu alua gotham
anand
aigen
and varoon amy what's your korean name
hondu
beautiful
i love that name that's a great name i
like that by the way why are you named
amy then when um my parents immigrated
to the u.s my mom was working as a nurse
and adapting to english and she just
could not handle all the complicated
hard spellings of her patients names so
she named her two daughters the easiest
english names that she could think of
which were amy and sandy and amy in
particular is because carter was in
office when i was born and they thought
that amy carter was like the cutest
little girl you're named after amy
carter that is precious
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you